[Music]
They kept the first manufacturers in
juvenile aquaria and
it was already clear to me back then that I wanted
to warn against weber's weeks this group of
fish from extinction.
The loss of species
didn't seem dramatic at first glance
. It disappears, but that's how it is
species coexist in a network
and if one species fails
this can have dramatic effects on the
whole network in which the
house we can now also galactic
fish are just my work is my
hobby and my passion and that's
actually all very nice
that resulted from that  my work as a
fisheries biologist i had the
opportunity to work with these fish every
day and the aim of the whole
thing is that you
build up old populations yourself in several construction phases
in the first year it was still so that
you then raised them for half a year
then in the  donau omit
this strange feeling but meanwhile
relatively nice feeling to then
be able
to release them into the wild it is now so that we
release almost 130000 fish
we were definitely curious what
the next few years of monitoring will
bring without the implementation of
european water law it would be this
form of protection or
restoration  of rivers
so that's what really affects us
300 exactly what you stay big problems
don't leave them at national
level and the disrupters set a good example in
addition they don't stop at borders
and it needs real
cooperation between everyone
involved, but it's only possible if
we pull together it's
very simple it's not about
whether you get the individual doctor
or not, it's about whether i
as a society
want to live in a healthy ecosystem i believe that
we owe it to future generations
sun biodiversity  there
is for them to obtain
[music]